hey guys so I'm here with Lizzy and
we're best friends yeah and I'm so
excited because you just started a
really fun project I did this is
actually launched morning when you're
watching this it's not launched morning
but right now it's launched morning and
it's launched morning for Kickstarter my
first documentary I'm so excited I'm
suicide you've got so many cameos of
people in your video I did and you're
one of them
yeah I know thank you do you want to
tell everyone a brief background on your
story and how you got started because
it's such an awesome stories yeah well
kind of a short summary of a long story
I was born with a rare syndrome that
only two other people in the entire
world including myself at and it's not
diagnosed bla bla bla I can we can eat
whatever I want
kay kay wait ba ba ba it's something
interesting okay maybe it is and it's
been kind of a difficult life I mean
dealing with the syndrome and mean
people out there but I kind of found the
happy Road and I want to take you guys
on the happy road with me and we're
hoping to do that with this documentary
to show people like not only my story
but kind of that there's a light at the
end of the tunnel when you're bullied
and we want to kind of make the internet
a more positive place I think that's so
important because I'm even just reading
YouTube comments I mean it's it's just a
never ending well it depends what you're
reading but I mean there's so many
supportive people but then if you just
try to bring you down for no reason yeah
why Allah gives you notice under social
media there can be so many people that
are supporting you yeah it's so nice and
then there's that one person that says
something that and then all of those
nice people turn into the bully oh yeah
and then they start you know trying to
support you and then stick up for you
which is it is awesome because you have
created such a good community of people
that
just happy and willing to fight you yeah
definitely yeah porn is so awesome we
actually met at one of my favorite
places ever it's just so so happy
I don't even how did that all even come
about at her it wasn't even that long
ago no it was like last year but I've
been following you on Instagram and on
YouTube for like years
no yeah yeah for like a while I was
falling into camera and then finally I
just like left a comment and then I went
on a binge watch of all of your meals
for love it's a like I'm not joking 3:30
in the morning
that is one funny okay this all just
randomly happened I was like you're not
gonna be in New York are you and I
reaction when you texted me is like yes
yes I haven't good to be in New York
there was like a big youtube thing going
on so I was like well there's a small
chance maybe Lizzie will be in New York
cuz you were in LA and I was here again
we're always missing each other I know
I'm either here or awesome and right now
we're sitting on the floor we're sitting
on the park is our lovely hotel house
it's great we're in like a cafeteria
we're in the continental the continental
breakfast give me that you already show
you guys like this is where we are right
now
listen self/psyche I want to make a
video I want to talk about your
Kickstarter this is so awesome
the lizzie project comm we're doing so
many cool hashtags with the first month
of the Ursuline is I'm with Lizzy if you
kind of tweet anything about the
Kickstarter documentary anything you
want to tell me hashtag I'm Lizzy and
I'll see it
let's talk great and you're so good with
social media and you're on set like
honestly you're just always updating and
it's like a job it is but you enjoy
though I do I love it I love it it's
like you have your internet buddy so
yeah I have to keep them updated and I'm
doing so much stuff now that I just want
to take them with me you know so guys
make sure you go check out our
Kickstarter I am so excited because as
we say this right now it's not really
launched yet this is like launch date
like oh I've been counting down the days
have you seen my clues yes I did and I'm
like I know it's happening and these
clues don't exist they're the worst
things I've ever seen because I couldn't
even get if you won of that might third
day yeah I 3 was my favorite because it
was lights camera action with the first
be you okay it was the only action
picture of me being physical okay I
didn't get the booze and the sunglasses
light I'll go along with the camera
these are you Moody these are way too
deep just be at least I didn't come up
with them I just chose two pictures I
would not have guessed
today's clue I have to tell you what
today's Clues gonna be even look at you
right now yeah because it won't with a
large easy
doing that and we wrote the Lizzie
project on it with the Jade I took a
picture with it and that's gonna be in
final clue lily is oh yeah I don't know
what to say like I'm so excited for you
because - I can't believe this is
happening
I'm speechless and I can't wait it's
been the story of my life the capacity
the Lord is that onedirection and
excellent I think it is right oh my gosh
I'm sorry one Directioners one
Directioners are so mad we both like
slept three hours yeah not oh I was
actually surprised when I saw emails
belly then I know I stayed out we were
celebrating it's a gun shooting in New
York so it's like oh great I was like I
have to get up I have to see Lizzie it's
gonna be my nighttime I want to do is
just sleep I'm celebrating like the face
events for blush because I just
discovered blush I saw you were Santa
Monica yeah you were thirsty in exactly
where you'll see movies photos I'm like
that's my stomping ground I know that so
and I talked about you my blog I was
like listen I just want to go here
because just even post videos by this
Apple Store and I mean everyone liked
who I was what what like just look at
the store just a few weirdo look at the
store and I was like just seemed instant
there did you post it yet did blah
no I didn't uh yet oh my we'll see okay
of all Maya California injures from that
crazy days but I mean I was so upset
because that that's like third street
that's my that's the one place I wanted
to go to it's so great there's so many
cool people and it's just like thing is
just awesome it was I was happy to have
to go but I was so tired that we just
went to lush and left and it got
backwards it's okay that's worth it and
you got to see the Apple Store which is
again that was sell ourselves here
good yeah think you got everything
covered Jarell Wendy's oh it's been so
cold actually
alright guys we could probably sit here
oh my god we've been talking for 10
minute just in here chat and just
walk her with what if I call mostly the
light of all people
well I make sure you check out Lizzie's
container everywhere on the internet
everywhere it's the Lizzie project calm
yes the Lizzie project design project
calm yeah and you see just Eve on the
teeth okay okay my god I know I have a
bigger treat but I'm going to need your
help for this one my dream is sick to
leave the online community better off
and I found it